here in Washington our leaders spent the
week focused on the Middle East on Iran
but out there in the rest of the country
there are plenty of more pressing
concerns tangible concerns for example
many of our cities are starting to fail
infrastructure is aging
both crime and the cost of living are
surging and left-wing prosecutors have
stopped enforcing the law I'll have more
on all of that in part four of our
American dystopias series in just a
moment but for the leading Democratic
presidential candidate Joe Biden of
Delaware none of these problems matches
what he believes is the greatest crisis
of all America isn't importing enough
desperately poor people that's his
position in a tweet on January 5th Biden
lashed out at the president for his
immigration policies quote our Statue of
Liberty invites in the tired the poor
the huddled masses yearning to breathe
free
Donald Trump has slammed the door in the
face of families fleeing persecution and
violence end quote
quite a moralizer that Joe Biden
Minister a few months ago Biden vowed
that if when he becomes president he'll
admit two million poor immigrants
overnight and then increased that number
from their watch we could afford to take
in a heartbeat another two million
people the idea that a country of 330
million people cannot absorb people who
are in desperate need and who are
justifiably fleeing oppression is
absolutely bizarre absolutely bizarre I
would also move to increase the total
number of immigrants able to come to the
United States how many of those
immigrants will be staying into a
Biden's house at Joe Biden's expense mmm
zero of course Biden's view is that our
chief mission as a nation is to admit as
many poor people as we possibly can the
less impressive their country of origin
unless they're able to contribute to
this country the more we want them your
rich they are poor therefore you must
give them money the right to vote a
permanent home and once you've done that
repeat Biden claims that's our moral dd
the Donald Trump and anyone else who
shirks that duty is a racist but is
Trump sure
that Duty is the basic claim even true
it's worth assessing there's so much
lying so once again we go to the numbers
and here's what they are from October
2018 to September 2019 the Border Patrol
apprehended 977 thousand people at the
us-mexico border
that's the highest total in more than a
decade and more than the previous two
years combined now keep in mind that
just people being caught at the southern
border many more are getting through
without being caught of course and then
there are the tens or hundreds of
thousands of others who enter legally
but then overstay their visas these
illegal immigrants are tethering
themselves here with millions of anchor
babies it's not a talking point it's a
fact according to the Center for
Immigration Studies for example 372
thousand children of illegal aliens were
born in this country just last year
every one of them is now an American
citizen and their parents are benefiting
from a whole suite of benefits food
stamps Medicaid other programs and of
course they won't be deported down
wonder how we got 22 million illegal
immigrants that's how so by any actual
measure by the data illegal immigration
is worse than it has been in a long time
but for Joe Biden it's still not enough
22 million illegals why not
30 million or 50 million and every one
of them gets free health care paid for
by you that's his promise is your
country really so spectacularly rich
that we can afford this and of course
you know the answer we're not a rich
country we're more than 20 trillion
dollars in debt our middle class is
dying in part because the immigrants
willing to work for less have driven
down wages it doesn't make the
immigrants bad they're coming from
incredibly poor places with totally
different standards of living but it's
an economic fact that when you flood the
labor pool with people willing to work
for less wages go down and that's been
going on for decades not surprisingly
America's most immigrant heavy state
California is also the most impoverished
many people born in California can't
leave quickly enough ask Idaho in Texas
but Joe Biden says we need more
according to Biden our country's is
sanctuary must be a saint
for those fleeing violence but because
Joe Biden knows nothing he's not aware
that some of America's cities are
deadlier than the places those people
are fleeing from for example El Salvador
one third of all living el Salvadorans
Salvadorans live in this country now but
here are the numbers Salvador has 50
murders per hundred thousand people last
year Baltimore not a country the city in
Maryland Baltimore had 51 per hundred
thousand in other words it's more
dangerous than all Salvador Baltimore
clearly hasn't benefited at all from
America's policy of unlimited
immigration but you know none of this
matters because for people like Joe
Biden and the rest of this country's
ruling class helping American citizens
stop being the point a long time ago the
point is getting reelected and feeling
virtuous well speaking of in 2018
Oakland Mayor Libby Schaaf that national
attention by warning the illegal aliens
in her city about an impending federal
ice raid it is a continued perpetuation
of a racist lie that immigrants are not
valued members of our society we in
Oakland know better we in Oakland have a
community that welcomes and honors all
people no matter where they came from or
how they got here oh she's an incredibly
good person unlike you racist
thanks to Libby shafts efforts several
wanted criminals eluded Isis gap grasp
and Oakland became a top haven for
illegal immigrants running from the law
one of those immigrants has now taken a
life according to police Madison Alondra
suzanne white Kara was murdered by
Roberto Martinez in a road rage incident
last month by the time police identified
Martinez as the killer he had already
fled the country